what do you know about the multiverse
it's the most fantastic new phase of
marvel the chaos behind the scenes of
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness was almost as intense as the mcu
fracturing into millions of different
universes do you dare to know more i
can't wait to see how the audiences
respond to what we've done
number one
one thing that was new for doctor
strange was the way the team handled
spell casting the actors were given
lights on their hands because it created
the proper lighting on their faces and
costumes which would make the lives of
those working on the scenes in post just
a little bit easier elizabeth was not a
huge fan but that's
so silly as she put it they've been able
to figure it out without that it sounds
like she did not exactly enjoy working
with the hand lights we imagine they
would be quite blinding and cause
squinting but that's just our guess well
it appears elizabeth must have forgotten
about the lights because she can be seen
wearing them in end game perhaps they
just got a lot more use in doctor
strange than they did in wanda vision
number two stunts are like pizza crust
they're the best part actually yeah
something did now that you're saying
that something did go wrong while olsen
was wired up she left onto a pillar but
there was some rigging that went wrong
and the platform wasn't properly secured
and i fell straight through it
surprisingly she came out of it without
a scratch no cuts and bruises but it was
it scared me but elizabeth loves her
stunts elizabeth's not a fan of
adrenaline rushes like roller coasters
but she does like stunt work you feel
very youthful when you're being just
pulled around on a string she was
excited to try out one that was a bit
different from anything else she'd ever
done before she was hooked up on a rig
and a man jumped off a ladder and him
jumping off the ladder made me get go in
the sky
number three why does a sorcerer need to
be jacked for benedict cumberbatch fight
scenes were a challenge since he's
getting older uh which i love but you
really feel it the next day cumberbatch
got totally ripped for the movie but why
it may just be that we see a version of
doctor strange that doesn't like wearing
shirts or perhaps cumberbatch got
shredded just so he would have the
endurance to do the intense stunts day
in and day out
number four cue the dramatic music
somebody on set was out to get elizabeth
olsen just kidding in the scene with the
apple blossoms the white stuff floating
around in the air was actually burnt wax
she wound up really sick from it and
unfortunately then went on to do one of
the biggest scenes in the film while
feeling ill there's a lot of weird
things i think that we inhale on sets
that aren't very good for you number
five everybody gets an upgrade or two or
three in the multiverse the costumes in
the movie were on full display at the
premiere of the multiverse of madness dr
strange's classic outfit has been
updated since spider-man no way home and
overall this new one feels more cohesive
with the reds in the shirt matching the
reds in the cloak he was previously in a
disciple costume and that isn't the case
anymore they've also abandoned the
checker pattern in the undershirt and
updated his belt and cuffs to match it's
pretty awesome to see how the costume
designers borrowed from the comics to
create the new doctor strange costumes
but also how they take inspiration from
the earth 199 999 version aka the mcu
doctor we know and love mordo swapped
out bright greens for muted greens and
golds america chavez's jacket was done
with intricate hand-painted graffiti the
scarlet witch costume now has sleeves
and a more ancient feel to it and wong
is really embracing that sorcerer
supreme life with his updated outfit
number 6. ironically getting the movie
filmed was pure madness for the creative
team between the original director scott
derrickson quitting the sequel over
creative differences and kovid bringing
everything to a halt it's amazing we
ever got this movie at all part of that
is thanks to the duo that was sam raimi
and michael waldron both waldron and
raymie spent months salvaging and
reshooting multiverse of madness kovid
delaying the project gave sam and
michael the chance to ask if we wanted
to start over from scratch what would
our version of the movie be so they
started over the pandemic was a blessing
as they had more time to bring their
vision to life and do it justice the
team was still doing extensive reshoots
in early 2022 that were needed to
clarify the story and the original
release date was pushed back from may
25th to may 6th number 7. no way home
gave us our favorite spideys and doctor
strange gave us our favorite director
elizabeth olsen has loved working with
raymie saying he's a great energy and a
very specific filmmaker and loves
playing with his camera it's been fun
technology has come a long way since the
2001 spider-man we no longer like in the
first spider-man movie had to make the
tools to make the tools which would save
a ton of time and innovation zoom was
the big game changer for him though the
fact that he could contact 50 teammates
explain a concept and have the whole
team share all of their work
conveniently despite the different
mediums was phenomenal number eight set
in new york filmed almost exclusively in
england almost the entire movie was
filmed in studio on the lot in london
england at long cross studios the scene
with the big one-eyed squid monster
gargantos was built on a backlot in
total they built four city blocks for
the scene because they needed a huge
pallet to make that sequence work other
locations included burrough hill cider
farm freemasons hall los angeles
richmond park and vancouver
number nine imagine doctor strange if it
had the tone of a pixar movie kevin
feige brought sam raimi on board because
everybody knows he specializes in horror
films and that was the tone feige wanted
the sequel to have the reason this was
the right time to introduce this tone
was because the multiverse makes you
realize if there's something cool out
there there's also something dangerous
there's also something scary there's
also something hiding under your bed
number 10 it'll be hard to stay composed
with music like this composer danny
elfman believes the key to interweaving
the suspense for him was any movie like
this is a giant puzzle what made doctor
strange stand out was that just in this
particular puzzle there was some horror
for some of the horror music he used a
special extra-low brass sound that's
reminiscent of old-fashioned horror
sound he really likes number 11. she's
got the star power sochi gomez is
playing a 14 year old version of america
chavez which is younger than any of the
versions in the comics elizabeth gave
sochi great advice when she first
started out and that was never be shy
about giving any notes tips or opinions
on things chavez is an openly queer hero
and the actor and movie are the subjects
of controversy over not her sexuality
but 12 seconds of her talking about her
two moms disney refuses to cut the scene
for releases in other countries sochi
said it's a big deal that america is in
this movie it's just huge and i'm just
so happy that marvel has stuck to it and
kept the scene in there and it's just
pretty crazy that i get to be the one
who plays america
number 12 the multiverse is an actor's
playground elizabeth olsen flew to
london just two days after wrapping
wandavision to film multiverse of
madness i just keep coming back and i'm
always surprised every time wanda has a
newfound confidence olson is always
referring back to other films but keeps
adding new elements she thinks audiences
will enjoy but we basically all just
look like fools while we're filming
benedict cumberbatch loves playing
different versions of doctor strange
saying so to play different versions of
him really tick that box rachel mcadams
hasn't been around for the many many
movies the others have i had to go back
to my notes
but she also played different versions
of herself and so got to start fresh
didn't we tell you it was going to be
complete and utter chaos why didn't you
believe us what do you think doctor
strange 2 would be like if it didn't run
into all of these barriers let us know
your thoughts in the comments and thanks
for hanging out with us here at the
things